PAUL IRISH: Hi, and welcome to
Blink Questions Answered.
Over the past day we've
collected hundreds of
questions and votes from
you, getting your
questions about Blink.
And today we're going to be
answering all the top
questions with this panel.
So as a matter of
introduction, my
name is Paul Irish.
And I'm a developer advocate
on the Chrome team.
And we have a whole host of
other really smart folks to
answer these questions.
So if you can introduce.
DARIN FISHER: Hi, I'm
Darin Fisher.
I'm engineering lead for the
Chrome web platform team.
ALEX KOMOROSKE: I'm
Alex Komoroske.
I'm a product manager on the
Chrome web platform team.
ERIC SEIDEL: My name
is Eric Seidel.
I'm a long time WebKit
contributor, and now a member
of the Blink team.
PAUL IRISH: Great.
So we're just going to go
through from the top questions
that were submitted and voted
up by everyone, and get some
answers to some of the things
that everyone's wondering
about with the new Blink
announcement.
The first one that we have
is from Peter Kasting.
And it's a three-parter.
But I'll read it
out right now.
What will be the relationship
between the WebKit and Blink
code bases going forward?
Will the Chromium port be
removed from WebKit?
Is there any policy or tooling
to ensure that changes, either
bug fixes and features,
in one code base
migrate to the other?
ERIC SEIDEL: I'll take that.
There's no real formal
relationship
between the two teams.
I expect that they'll be
sharing ideas and some
patches, maybe more so
in the beginning.
In the beginning it'll be
easier to share patches.
Over time I expect that the two
code bases will diverge,
and will become not as easy
to share patches.
As far as the removal of
Chromium port from WebKit,
that's really up to the WebKit
project to figure out what
makes sense for them.
It'll be interesting to
see how it evolves.
I think there's people on both
sides who care passionately
about the web platform,
and the web platform
implementations that are
in WebKit and in Blink.
And people will be motivated
to share ideas.
ALEX KOMOROSKE: I should point
out, too, that we already work
with other browser
vendors as well.
Standards, activities, and
informal discussions, and
filing bugs, and commenting
on their bug databases.
And I imagine this will
be no different.
PAUL IRISH: Great.
The next question is
about availability.
A lot of people were
curious about this.
So we got a question from Mihai
in Bucharest, and from a
number of other people.
When will Blink ship
on Canary?
When will it be available
in stable?
How far along in development
is it?
ALEX KOMOROSKE: One thing that I
want to emphasize is that at
the very beginning there's
really nothing
different from WebKit.
It's over time that they will
evolve in different
directions.
Technically, today's canary
will be using Bink.
But in reality there's going
to be no difference for web
developers, nothing that
you can even see.
The user agent, for example,
will remain the same for the
time being.
PAUL IRISH: If you want,
you can test out
today's canary build.
Blink is in it.
But really it's basically
the exact same
as yesterday's canary.
So you won't have any big
changes to deal with.
We'll move forward.
What is the plan for
transitioning the WebKit
integrated in Android
to Blink look like?
So what's the story for the
Chrome on Android and the
stock Android browser?
DARIN FISHER: I think the story
is very similar to the
previous question.
Chrome, going forward will be
using Blink instead of WebKit.
That means Chrome,
on all platforms,
will be using Blink.
The second part about that, the
Android browser, that has
to do with the product
cycle for Chrome,
and Chrome on Android.
As far as this team is focused
on, we're just trying to make
sure that Blink runs really
great, and is a great web
rendering engine for Chrome, on
all platforms where Chrome
can be found.
PAUL IRISH: I should point out
that Chrome and Android will
essentially have Blink
as of version 28.
This is the same for
Chrome on desktop.
So 28 is the first
Chrome release.
It's in its canary right now.
And it'll be in stable in
about 10-ish weeks.
Hopefully, we'll see.
DARIN FISHER: I'm not
sure when they'll be
pushing the next beta.
PAUL IRISH: There's a Chrome on
Android beta via the Play
store they can take a look at.
Not exactly sure when
it'll be there.
Again, don't expect
any big changes.
It's the same code base,
for the most.
In some of the documentation
that came out yesterday, there
was a point around some of the
architectural changes that
we're looking at.
So one of them was we said, we'd
like to exploring larger
ideas, like moving the entire
DOM into JavaScript.
This has the potential to make
JavaScript DOM access
dramatically faster.
Is there anything that we
can elaborate on on
this kind of idea?
ERIC SEIDEL: I'm happy
to take that.
So one of things to understand
is the Document Object Model,
the DOM is implemented in the
part we call WebCore,
which is all C++.
And when you, in your JavaScript
page, access the
DOM, your code has to leave the
JavaScript virtual machine
and enter into WebCore.
There's a cost of that.
And although it's pretty
fast today, we'd like
it to be way faster.
And the way to make it way
faster is for your code to not
ever have to leave the
JavaScript virtual machine,
but instead be able to access
the DOM directly.
And to do that we'd have to move
the DOM into JavaScript.
And this is one of the many
crazy ideas that were
exploring in the future
of Blink.
DARIN FISHER: Crazy, because
it's not exactly
an automatic win.
There's pros and cons
to any such change.
And we're going to explore that,
and see what kind of
benefits we can derive and what
opportunities can be had
from such a crazy idea that.
ALEX KOMOROSKE: There
are a lot of ideas
on the project page.
We're just collecting a wish
list of things we want to look
into and investigate
that now we can.
Because we can change
architectural boundaries if
necessary, and really
dream big.
I think we're all really excited
try all these crazy
ideas, and see which
ones work.
PAUL IRISH: Another question
that we had--
this is from Greg again--
something
that was in the Docs.
This was around removing
things.
We had a note and there around
removing obscure parts of the
DOM, and making backwards
incompatible changes to
obscure parts that benefit
performance or remove
complexity.
What can we share around this?
ERIC SEIDEL: I'm happy
to take that as well.
This actually a larger trend in
the web platform right now.
If you look at HTML5, HTML5 did
a lot of work to try to
remove some of the old crufty
bits that were perhaps speced
in HTML2 or 3, but haven't
been used in 20 years.
A good example of this is the
isindex tag, which was an idea
long ago, and has now been
replaced by a much simpler
implementation in HTML5.
And the same thing is true of
these things called entity
reference nodes, which exists
technical in the DOM, but
nobody's ever used.
So we've been removing these
out of WebKit and out of
Blink, as the specs have moved
forward to also remove them.
DARIN FISHER: But we plan to
do so very carefully, to
ensure that we are not breaking
or torturing web
developers along the way.
The idea is to identify the low
hanging fruit, and clean
up the platform, if we can.
And hopefully in a way that
moves a platform forward in a
very positive way.
Because over time, if you just
keep accumulating features,
the platform suffers.
ALEX KOMOROSKE: We've been
investigating looking at, for
example, across the web with the
search index, and seeing
where these different features
are being used.
We published a few
of those results.
We're looking into that more.
Because that helps give us a
better lens into what features
are actually being used, and how
much of a risk there is in
removing them.
Certain features, like isindex,
no one's using that.
But other ones, it
helps figure out
which ones you can--
[INAUDIBLE]
responsibly.
DARIN FISHER: Sometimes we have
to do some work to help
people migrate.
We have some evangelism
work, and so on.
Because there can be some people
stuck on an old way of
doing something.
And there's a new way that
would be better.
PAUL IRISH: Some of that, taking
a look at the real
world usage of CSS, whether
the prefix to prefix DOM
things, we've looked into this
as a way to identify how we
can responsibly deprecate
things like prefixed CSS
properties as well.
ALEX KOMOROSKE: We announced
yesterday that going forward
we'll have a policy of no vendor
prefixes, which is
similar to what Mozilla
is doing, and the
policy they've adopted.
There are a lot of legacy
prefixes for
stuff that we've inherited.
And over time, on a case
by case basis, we'll be
investigating which of these
we can just deprecate the
prefix version, because the
non-prefixed version works.
Which ones are nonstandard?
Should those just be
fully deprecated?
Should they be standardized?
And really on a case by case
basis trying to work
through this list.
Ultimately, sometime in the
future, getting to a point
where hopefully there
are no prefixes.
That'll take us some
time to get to.
We have to do it responsibly
so we don't break stuff.
PAUL IRISH: Next question is,
what will prevent the same
collaborative development
difficulties that hampered
WebKit emerging in Blink as it
gains more contributors, and
is ported to more platforms?
DARIN FISHER: The key comment
here is porting.
And actually Blink will be built
on a virtual platform,
if you will, that doesn't
require a lot of porting
effort to bring it
to new platforms.
You can see already that Chrome
runs on variety of
devices, from desktop down
to embedded systems.
And the point is that not a
lot of work is required to
move that code base across
these different systems.
This is all true because
Chromium's sandboxed,
multi-process architecture
forced us to take away
OS-specific integration
from the web platform
implementation, from WebKit.
So we, over the course of
time, developed this
abstraction layer, this virtual
platform on which
WebKit's built.
And going forward with Blink,
that's the only platform that
will support Blink, which means
that it will be very
portable code base.
We've already seen people
having plenty of success
taking Chromium's content
layer, which is the
multi-process embedding
layers, that it
will enclose Blink.
And they've taken that to many
other platforms, and used it
in many different sorts of
applications, all without
having to substantially fork
or add code to Chromium.
We're really excited about the
prospects of allowing a lot of
people to participate on Blink,
and make use of it in
new ways, without having to
torture the code base with a
lot of ifdefs or variations.
ALEX KOMOROSKE: Paul, you had a
post a few weeks ago that I
thought was amazing.
I learned a lot from that
post, actually.
And you talked about how there
are different layers in WebKit
supporting them all.
You have to bring a lot of
things to the table, every
platform you want to run on.
And with Blink, in with the
content layer, you get all
this stuff just more easily.
We don't have to implement
a special version.
DARIN FISHER: You get a
cross-platform implementation
of these things.
It isn't like it's
an atomic unit.
There is some modularity
to it.
It allows people to subtract
modules that they don't want
to bring with them
to the platform.
But we strive in the Chromium
to modularize, as opposed to
using preprocessor directives
to hack up the code base.
PAUL IRISH: Say, for instance,
V8 and Skia-- do those come
along with the content
layer of Chromium?
DARIN FISHER: That's right.
V8 and Skia are implied
by this system.
So Blink will depend on Skia
for its graphics and V8 for
its JavaScript engine.
ALEX KOMOROSKE: And actually
that coupling allows us to
potentially change those
architectural layers, they way
those interact, and
optimize those.
DARIN FISHER: This is a really
important point.
I think both the Skia team and
V8 are both pretty excited
about the opportunity to improve
the integration of
those libraries with the
rendering engine.
That's going to mean changes
in those interfaces.
PAUL IRISH: Great.
Moving on to the next question,
will the changes
from Blink be contributed back
to the WebKit project.
ERIC SEIDEL: They're
separate projects.
Definitely when we forked WebKit
from KHTML, we saw a
lot of changes that got moved
back and forth between the
code bases.
Because they began
so similarly.
And I would predict that similar
effects will happen
with Blink.
But they are separate
projects.
They are separate code bases.
And we don't have any
plans, currently,
to be moving patches.
ALEX KOMOROSKE: But they're
both open source.
ERIC SEIDEL: They're
And anybody can do that.
ALEX KOMOROSKE: Over time, as
they evolve in different
directions, that will get
harder and harder to do.
But in the beginning especially,
hopefully it won't
be too hard for sharing
back and forth.
DARIN FISHER: I think those
watching the change logs and
will see probably see some
Googlers contributing some
changes to WebKit, certainly
in the near term.
I think over time that will
probably diminish.
PAUL IRISH: The next question,
Google said problems living
with the WebKit2 multi-process
model was a prime reason to
create Blink.
But Apple engineers say they
asked to integrate Chromium's
multi-process into WebKit prior
to creating WebKit2 and
were refused.
What gives?
DARIN FISHER: It's true that
Apple, shortly after launching
Chrome, Apple expressed interest
in our multi-process
layer that we had developed.
I think it's important to
understand that that code
base, the multi-process
layer was fairly
mature at that point.
We had launched Chrome.
We had developed a system that
was very coupled into Chrome's
system, it's way
of doing stuff.
It leveraged libraries that
WebKit didn't use, and so on.
And so for us we viewed that
opportunity to work with Apple
on the multi-process code as--
actually that sounded quite
exciting to us.
However, we saw that as a
mountain of work, a large,
technically challenging
engineering project for us.
Perhaps it's a matter of the
timelines not being favorable.
But we just didn't see a path
forward that allowed us to
contribute that code
to WebKit.
ALEX KOMOROSKE: But overall I
think what the teams ended up
doing was collaborating really
effectively within WebCore.
DARIN FISHER: We focused on
where we can maximize the
benefits of working together
with Apple.
And that was sharing WebCore.
The parts that is a very
sensitive part of the code
base, where HTML is parsed,
where the DOM is constructed,
where CSS is used to render that
DOM into the web pages as
we know it.
That part of the web, there was
so much value in sharing
that code that we did our best
to streamline or our way of
using WebKit, so that we could
get as many developers focused
on WebCore as possible, and
working with Apple.
And I think it's been
very successful.
Going forward, I think, as we
hinted to, there's some
significant changes that we want
to make that we feel will
affect the shape of WebCore in
ways that the WebCore project,
WebKit, might not be
ready to receive.
So we don't want to keep
on constraints.
That's what these us to
where we are today.
Do you guys have anything
to add?
ERIC SEIDEL: The reality is
they're just very different
architectures to serve
very different needs.
And the question of whether
WebKit could have adopted our
model, or whether we would
adopt their model are
questions comparing different
timelines.
One was five years ago.
One was a year or two ago.
So they're almost
incomparable.
But the reality is they're very
different architectures,
very different answers
to similar questions.
And we chose different paths.
And we successfully collaborated
in the WebKit
project for the last
five years.
And it's been great.
And I think we'll continue
to collaborate
with the WebKit project.
But we've chosen different
paths.
PAUL IRISH: Is there anything
that we can say around
Android's web view
implementation and its
adopting Blink?
DARIN FISHER: Those following
along in the Chromium project
can see that there's been
development of Android web
view API on top of Chrome.
In the fullness of time, when
that comes to Android, then
Blink will come to Android.
I'm excited about that.
I think it's great from our
point of view of our team to
help enable the use of web view
to be based on Chrome.
So that we can help
make it better.
And have it be based on
Blink means we can
help make it be better.
I'm excited about that.
PAUL IRISH: Absolutely.
Will Blink be able to support
multiple scripting languages?
DARIN FISHER: Sorry, I think
our plan going forward--
I think this is a reference
to Dart, perhaps?
The Dart VM.
It's important to understand
that even today, you can go
and get Dartium, which is
a build of Chromium,
uses the Dart VM.
And the engineers working on
that project have developed a
patch that allowed them to add
the Dart VM to WebKit in a way
that wasn't terribly disruptive
to WebKit.
The reason why Dart VM is not
in Chromium today doesn't
really have to do with whether
or not WebKit supports or
Blink supports multiple VMs.
It has a lot more to do with
the timeline for the Dart
itself, and getting to the point
where we feel like we
can make a long term-- or should
make a long term--
commitment to the Dart VM.
ALEX KOMOROSKE: We have very
strong principles, with Blink
especially, about compatibility
risk, and making
sure that we responsibly
ship new features.
These are things that we are
going to hold all features up
to as we decide whether
or not to ship them.
DARIN FISHER: I think somebody
made a really good point.
I forget who it was.
Maybe one of the other engineers
on our team.
He said, whatever we do,
whatever we put in Blink, it's
got to fit on here.
And so we can't just put
everything in there just
because it seems like
a good idea.
We have to validate that.
And be confident that we can
stick with that decision, make
a long term commitment.
And build this platform
responsibly.
We don't want to have--
this relates to our
whole strategy
around deprecating APIs.
We don't want to be in a
situation where we have to
deprecate API.
So we don't want to add multiple
different ways of
doing the same thing.
I think the web platform is
famous for having multiple
solutions to the same problem.
And we see that as a problem.
We have to be responsible
to not create
more of those problems.
PAUL IRISH: This is a question
from spiffytech.
How does the Chromium team
expect this will affect the
myriad of other browsers that
have adopted WebKit.
ALEX KOMOROSKE: I should say,
too, one thing to start off.
We fundamentally believe that
having multiple rendering
engines will help spur
innovation, and is ultimately
good for the long-term
health of the web.
And so in that respect, I
think it's actually very
healthy for the whole
ecosystem.
So just to get started
with that.
DARIN FISHER: As a team, we're
really focused on web
standards, and sharing tasks,
and helping this ecosystem of
browsers all agree on what the
web platform should be.
But having multiple
implementations is really valuable.
Without that, developers are
stuck maybe with the quirks of
a particular engine.
And that's not healthy
for the platform.
It's not great for developers,
as far as we can tell.
ERIC SEIDEL: I hope, if anything
it just gives other
browsers choice.
Embedding WebKit is not
comparable, really, to
embedding Blink.
Because Blink requires the
Chromium content layer.
So you would embed the Chromium
content layer if you
wanted to embed Blink.
But it just gives you choice.
PAUL IRISH: I think
we covered this.
Does this mean that Google stops
contributions to WebKit?
ERIC SEIDEL: Google contributed
WebKit before
Chrome was announced.
And I expect that Google will
continue to contribute after.
DARIN FISHER: I think is
important to say that, as
Google, we're not telling
people they shouldn't
contribute to WebKit.
We're just telling them that,
feel free to focus on Blink.
ERIC SEIDEL: Chromium is
going to ship Blink.
And so the Chromium team
is focused on Blink.
But that doesn't mean that other
parts of Google, or even
parts of the Blink team--
some of us are long time
WebKit contributors.
I plan to post patches
to WebKit.
I expect other of my
colleagues do too.
PAUL IRISH: What open source
license will Blink have?
Will it continue to support
the H.264 codec?
DARIN FISHER: There's no
relicensing happening as part
of this fork.
PAUL IRISH: What's the--
DARIN FISHER: It's a collage
of licenses.
ALEX KOMOROSKE: A collage--
that's a good
way of putting it.
DARIN FISHER: The history of
WebKit is that it's absorbed
code from a variety
of projects.
I think a lot of it is BSD.
ERIC SEIDEL: BSD and LGPL.
DARIN FISHER: Will it continue
to support the H.264 codec?
That's really more of
a Chrome question.
ERIC SEIDEL: Blink doesn't know
what codecs even exist.
It has a box in which
the video goes.
And something outside of Blink
makes the video go there.
So Blink doesn't care or know.
PAUL IRISH: We saw a lot of
questions about this.
People are curious about
the user-agent string.
Will we see a Blink keyword in
the user-agent string, like
KHTML, like Gecko?
DARIN FISHER: We have
no plans to change
the user-agent string.
And going forward, in fact,
there's a version number after
Apple WebKit and Safari.
At this point we have no plans
to change that number.
What will change, going forward,
is just to the number
after Chrome.
We, of course, lament the
use-agent string profusely.
But we also see that any changes
there have to be
handled very, very carefully.
Because, like it or not,
people do all kinds of
interesting string compares
against it.
ALEX KOMOROSKE: As you can tell
from looking at anyone's
user-agent string,
they're crazy.
I should say, too, this is the
kind of thing that ultimately,
if we revisit this--
I'm sure at some point we will--
will be doing it on
blink-dev, the open
mailing list.
And this will be definitely
discussion that we can take
care of for you if
we come to it.
DARIN FISHER: I think it was a
couple years ago that there
was a successful effort to trim
out a few bits of the
user-agent strings.
Certainly be looking
for opportunities.
I would love to see this
user-agent string be
simplified radically.
But it's hard to say when
or if that will happen.
ERIC SEIDEL: Just don't
want to break the web.
PAUL IRISH: Don't
break the web.
When we'll be able to test
the first version Blink?
Again this is available--
DARIN FISHER: Today.
PAUL IRISH: Blink is available
in Chrome Canary as of today.
DARIN FISHER: And you can
build it yourself.
This question was asking about
Blink in Chromium as well.
You can just build
it yourself.
ERIC SEIDEL: We had some
tireless infrastructure
engineers who stayed up all
night making that true.
ALEX KOMOROSKE: I was watching
blink-dev this morning.
I think people succeed in
building it, correct?
ERIC SEIDEL: Yes.
ALEX KOMOROSKE: So at this
point we're focusing--
ERIC SEIDEL: We have taken
patches already.
ALEX KOMOROSKE: Great.
ERIC SEIDEL: Blink is up
and running today.
You can build it today.
And I believe the Chromium
canary tomorrow is likely to
have Blink in it.
PAUL IRISH: Another thing I
wanted to ask about this, a
lot of people are used to
watching change that's coming
on the WebKit side.
To do the same in Blink,
we have a similar
way of doing that.
ERIC SEIDEL: We do have URLs.
I don't know them off
the top of my head.
ALEX KOMOROSKE: We do.
And I think it's on
the project page.
Our goal is for everyone to be
able to watch this, and watch
all the discussions and
bugs, and everything.
So if there is something where
it's hard to follow along, we
want to make that easier
for people.
ERIC SEIDEL: The easy way to
answer that is to join
blink-dev@chromium.org,
or to join the
#Blink channel on Freenode.
We've also talked about having
an IRC-based commit bot, just
like the WebKit project does,
where it tells you what the
commits as they come in.
But that's the way to answer
that question, is to join one
of our mailing lists or IRC.
PAUL IRISH: And all that
information is available on
chromium.org/blink, where you
can see our current mailing
lists, a link to where all the
change sets are coming in,
where you can browse them,
and everything else.
ALEX KOMOROSKE: One thing too,
watching the change sets takes
a lot of effort for a lot
of web developers.
And one thing that we're doing
is, especially recently, we're
getting better at having
summary posts.
And so we do that for every beta
release now for Chrome.
Those summarize what things
we've enabled, which things
are now behind a flag, which
prefixes we've deprecated.
That's a great way for web
developers to follow along,
where you don't have to be
reading every single commit
that's going through.
And chromestatus.com
is also great.
We're going to be--
Max and Eric were just
talking on blink-dev.
They have plans to make that
into more of a full future
dashboard which is
really cool.
PAUL IRISH: Chromestatus.com
lists out all the various
features of the platform that
are in discussion these days,
lists out what their
implementation status is, and
also what their standardization
status is
across the browser ecosystem.
ALEX KOMOROSKE: I
love watching.
If you haven't looked at it,
you should look at it.
It's really interesting
to get a snapshot.
DARIN FISHER: We all had this
idea in our head of what it
might look like.
But to actually see it.
ALEX KOMOROSKE: Oh wow,
it's very interesting.
PAUL IRISH: It's a great
snapshot of the web ecosystem
in one view.
And we've already been getting
some great contributions from
Adobe over the past two days.
ALEX KOMOROSKE: And
others, as well.
I think we got a few guys
from Mozilla also
helped us as well.
The goal is to have that be a
snapshot of the health, the
state, of the web ecosystem.
Specifically Chromium, but over
time it could be for the
whole web ecosystem.
I think that's cool.
We'll see.
PAUL IRISH: Next question.
How will this impacts Dart
language's process?
Can we expect a Dart
VM to be integrated
into Chrome as a result?
DARIN FISHER: I already
answered the question.
But I think it doesn't really
impact Dart language at all.
ERIC SEIDEL: Dart's a separate
open source project.
I don't think changes
to our open source
really affect them directly.
PAUL IRISH: When we get our
hands on Blink code?
Again, today.
Yesterday.
We're good.
Will this be a direct competitor
against Mozilla's
new engine?
Is co-working with Mozilla
out of the question?
ERIC SEIDEL: The engine I
believe they mean is Servo,
which although Brendan posted
about it yesterday, it's been
in the public for a long time.
ALEX KOMOROSKE: I remember
design docs
about that a year ago.
ERIC SEIDEL: I've been following
it for a while.
It's very, very cool
what they're doing.
ALEX KOMOROSKE: Really
cool ideas.
ERIC SEIDEL: But I don't see
Blink as really a direct
competitor.
DARIN FISHER: Blink is an
iteration from WebKit.
It's a fork of WebKit.
Servo is a new rendering engine
constructed from scratch.
ERIC SEIDEL: According to
their docs, it's an
experiment.
The docs say that they may
not actually ever ship.
So that's a very different kind
of project then Blink or
WebKit, which is
really about--
ALEX KOMOROSKE: A shipping
product.
ERIC SEIDEL: Yeah, it's
about an iteration.
One of WebKit's goals
was WebKit is
not a science project.
We're about shipping
a product today.
And the reality is the world
and the web ecosystem need
both kinds.
We need exploratory
crazy new things.
And we also need to ship
something today.
And Blink is about
shipping today.
ALEX KOMOROSKE: I think we're
really excited to see some of
those ideas they're trying.
Because we're trying to dream
big with our wish list of
things to try.
They're dreaming even bigger.
Because they're building
a new one from scratch.
ERIC SEIDEL: Which is amazing.
ALEX KOMOROSKE: And so that
will be really cool to see
which of those really big ideas
work, and which ones--
DARIN FISHER: I'm sure there
will be a lot of idea sharing.
ALEX KOMOROSKE: Absolutely.
ERIC SEIDEL: And I can
see the Mozilla
offices from my window.
And we talk to Mozilla guys
with some frequency.
And I think of them as very
cooperative, not competitors.
DARIN FISHER: Do they know
you can see them?
ERIC SEIDEL: I'm not sure.
PAUL IRISH: The buildings are
right next to each other.
ERIC SEIDEL: The buildings are
ALEX KOMOROSKE: Actually we
discussed this with some folks
from Mozilla.
They were visiting a few days
ago in the offices.
We talked about the fact
that we could see them.
PAUL IRISH: So the question
is about vendor prefixes.
When will the existing
vendor prefixes in
Blink be phased out?
ALEX KOMOROSKE: I think I
already touched on this as
part of an earlier question.
Again, going forward, no
new vendor prefixes.
But course there are
a number of legacy
ones that we've inherited.
DARIN FISHER: It could
take a long time to--
ALEX KOMOROSKE: It could
take a long time.
Because we want to do
it responsibly.
Want to figure out-- we don't
want to break the web.
So some of them are, there's
been the un-prefixed version
for years and years and years.
And no one's using the
prefix version.
Go ahead and take that out.
Other ones are things that
were never standardized.
And we want to either figure
out, should we
just deprecate these?
Or should we take these
to standardization?
But it's going to be a
case by case basis.
DARIN FISHER: I think this
really hits on the point.
And the reason why we don't
want to do vendor prefixes
anymore is because, vendor
prefix or not, when you add
something to the platform
and you ship it, you can
get stuck with it.
And it becomes part
of the platform.
And so adding vendor prefixes
just makes a big old mess.
It doesn't actually seem
to add any value.
ERIC SEIDEL: Standards bodies
have even discussed the idea
of needing to standardize WebKit
prefixed features,
which is crazy to me.
But may need to happen
if we fail to be
able to remove these.
ALEX KOMOROSKE: It's crazy.
Hopefully it doesn't
come to that.
DARIN FISHER: So there will
be no Blink prefix.
ERIC SEIDEL: There will
The madness must stop.
PAUL IRISH: I saw a request,
actually, that we would maybe
support -blink
text-decoration-blink.
DARIN FISHER: I'm pretty sure
we will not be doing that.
Maybe behind an enable
flag, just for fun.
ALEX KOMOROSKE: Someone
was joking--
I forget who it was--
joking that with web components
actually someone
could make an x-blink if they
really wanted to, their own
version of it.
We will not ship
the Blink tag.
That's for sure.
PAUL IRISH: I think that
can wrap it up for now.
I appreciate everyone
for submitting
questions, voting them up.
Hope we answered a lot
of your questions.
We'll be posting this video,
along with our
content already out there.
So if you haven't checked it
out, chromium.org/blink gives
an overview of the entire
project, our policies towards
adding features.
And then the Developer FAQ
answers a lot of other
questions that go along
with these ones.
So I encourage you to
check that out.
And I think that'll
wrap it up.
DARIN FISHER: Thank you.
PAUL IRISH: Thanks guys, very
much, for joining us.